we are here today celebrating the
passage of the gold medal for the six
triple a
[Applause]
celebration this week wisconsin
representative glenn moore celebrated
pat the passage of a bill she championed
awarding the congressional gold medal to
the six triple eight that's the
battalion number of the only all-female
all-black unit to serve in europe in the
second world war the women didn't
directly confront the enemy but they
battled something else a mountain of
mail which they managed to sort route
and deliver faster than anyone could
have imagined
when
mothers
were worried that their sons when wives
were worried
that their husbands had lost connection
who kept that connection going the six
triple h on monday the house of
representatives unanimously voted to
award the only all black women's army
corps unit to serve overseas in world
war ii one of the highest civilian
honors a congressional gold medal the
fact that they were not recognized was
unconscionable to me until now over 75
years later united states representative
gwen moore one of the bill's sponsors
pushed for that recognition this was an
experiment putting this six triple eight
postal battalion together
there was not a lot of confidence that
that black women could make a
contribution
[Music]
during world war ii through the women's
army corps about 6 500 black women
served in the military in the beginning
of 1945 when racial segregation was
still practiced
855 black service women went overseas to
serve in the central postal directory
battalion it was known as the sixth
triple eighth you know the six triple
eight were deployed to england and to
france
during the war
they came under fire
bomb threats but yet
they had the the spirit and attitude of
soldiers at a time when the only form of
communication to and from the front
lines came through the mail these women
were tasked with the job to sort through
a backlog of letters and packages
totaling around 17 million pieces
sorting an average of 65 thousand pieces
of mail per shift clearing a six-month
backlog in just three months
they fought for the morale
of our troops
their theme was no male
low morale in this case it was women of
the six triple eight who tried to make
sure soldiers knew they weren't
forgotten
and some now say it's our turn to do the
same for them these women served
and then they went back to their lives
facing discrimination
jim crow and none of them received any
veterans benefits i think a gold medal
of recognition is probably the very
least
we can do
they cut the backlog in half right
17 million pieces 65 000 pieces of paper
on average
per shift
and no veterans benefits i mean it just
it kills me i never heard of these women
right the fact that we don't know about
them and so many others there's so many
great stories we do now you have and now
we have and now we have
yeah the least what was it the least we
can do exactly the least we can do